first of all this first time we've had a
chance to sit down how are you doing I'm
good man
yeah better now that I see you my guy my
friend ah you know these moments always
oh good you all right so here we go it's
good to know that I got the
relationships that I have you know what
talking to you oh wow thank you man
you know thank you Kevin you married my
sister how she doing you good
all right I'll see you Thanksgiving
dinner okay all right I'm glad you guys
are hugging now let's go I'll see you at
dinner
hug it out for a second can we talk
about the real reason we are here and
that is Jumanji yes how was it making
this movie ah unreal so much fun
Wonderland would you look at me I
haven't looked like this since never you
look like this never I think my eyes are
a different color all of you is a
different color
you know you're looking at an
opportunity to repeat or surpass what we
did with the first one and have fun
doing so here's my question
have you been replaced now by Danny
DeVito is this his new partner his Road
Dogg a guy he kicks away there's a
couple of things that didn't sit well
with me you know and as it you just say
I'm not an emotional guy right but you
know we're in a relationship so that's
all seeing you or Danny and
Oh Oh twins thing it's like a little
that's not nothing here and that now's
not the time
but is it well there ever was a time
this is the time I just think that
there's only room for one little guy in
your life so and they too have another
it's like it's weird
well we're resting am i I mean is this a
thing you're not you're my number one
you should be posting would you post it
twice no but there's no threat to you
that's the thing because you wouldn't
really like him
that's weird cuz you you're like Danny
fly with me and I ask you I say do you
have room on a plane he like no cab I'm
going in early we're full but then I see
you were Danny on a tarmac right now
don't bring it up
what's that that but that's a real
situation for another time but not now
okay maybe immediately active or maybe
nothing
or maybe I like to anymore okay what
this is what we need to discuss is it
because of what is it is it is
well conversation she's a better kisser
this is Danny Glover was so excited
about you and the way you were trained
him that's a good guy oh my god my
joints feel like vada
release myself but he wasn't sure which
Danny Glover character it was was it
Murtagh was it mr. was it where'd you go
I went Murtagh I went I went Lethal
Weapon 4 okay
the older version of Danny wasn't Lethal
Weapon 4 and he was he was surrounded by
energy Joe Pesci Chris Rock and it was
all reactive in trying to get control
and everything was a little slow I think
for me to be reactive to the world that
we were gonna be in but it's a better
choice there's something like a ground I
felt and give myself a good opportunity
but having you know the big fella
portrayed David the veto how was come in
at the level that he did help a lot like
yeah you're looking at a gift you know
to be able to react though I think a lot
of people would be shocked that you're
Danny DeVito it was an honor you know to
really to embody him and I think that
you know with Kevin tonight those guys
they have a real relationship in real
life of over a 30-year I so they they
grounded the movie at the top of the
movie and Kevin and I were just able to
come in and do what we did and you know
we got really lucky to be able to embody
two guys who have very distinct acting
personalities and styles and who are
very hanging name just like Kevin and I
too as well so I love Kevin's
performance in this movie as Danny
Glover G just kills the boy did you love
his Halloween costume nailed it I hated
his Halloween costume now see where he
had my fanny pack he had you fit
everything did you see the napkin under
my elbow oh I just didn't like the way
he was standing what exactly is that one
oh I stood cooler I was like a G you
were like you were a little forward
interesting way I don't
all of the joists were all pretty bad I
don't make sure you saw the napkin that
wasn't at my L brighter a little story
about the neck Shelby kiss okay on a day
of the picture that was a choice to put
it on there cuz he didn't want to mess
up this black shirt she was they want to
get a shirt there
well you don't want to give that
turtleneck dirty where they say that
better uh flap turtleneck so he put a
napkin I took the picture a resourceful
man would do yeah right yeah it was
dirty I put a little napkin here someone
what you kept in a fanny pack did you
does the world know no and they
shouldn't they should
[Music]